[MUSIC PLAYING]
SMITA HASHIM: So,
good afternoon,
everyone, and welcome
to the session.
My name is Smita Hashim.
I'm the global product
management lead
for Chrome OS
Ecosystem products,
which is devices as well
as Android applications.
Today, me, along with my
colleagues, Shahid then Luis,
we will be talking to you about
Android apps for Chromebooks.
So, before I get
started, I wanted
to understand a little
bit more about you.
So, how many people are familiar
with the Chrome Operating
System?
So, everyone.
And how many of you--
I see some Chromebooks
in the room.
I see some people using them.
But how many of you have
used a Chromebook yourself?
OK, great.
Wow, this is great crowd.
We love this crowd.
And then, how many people here
are actually decision makers
for their businesses, in terms
of what would be deployed?
App developers?
Do we have any app
developers over here?
OK.
Yeah.
So, it's a mix, and we will be
going over a variety of topics
with you.
And we would love to take
any questions in the end.
So, we should go over
this pretty fast,
because most of the audience
seems familiar with the Chrome
Operating System.
But as you know, Chrome OS is
Google's productivity operating
system.
It's designed for
the large screens,
and it's designed with a few
guiding principles in mind.
So, first of this is speed.
So, if you have
used Chromebooks,
you know that they boot
up in eight to 10 seconds.
So, they're really fast.
And that was a fundamental
design consideration
for the team right
from the beginning.
The other part
about Chromebooks,
is they're very, very simple.
So, if you get a new Chromebook,
you are up and running on it--
if you have never used
a Chromebook before--
literally in a few minutes.
So, very easy to use for users,
but also very, very easy for
administrators to administrate.
And I think probably a lot
of people know that as well.
In terms of security, security
is built into Chromebooks
at every layer.
So, starting from the hardware,
to the operating system,
to the application layer,
all the applications
are sand boxed.
Which means that for
all your Chrome devices,
you can think of it as antivirus
is automatically built in.
You'd never have to
worry about security
patches, and downloads,
and things like that.
And last, is that
shareability is
inherent to the
design of Chromebooks.
So, you can literally
grab any Chromebook,
and it's yours as soon as you
sign in, within a few seconds.
And that's a feature
which schools love.
So, students can grab any
Chromebooks and use them,
and increasingly,
businesses as well.
So, the users have
actually responded really
well to these design principles.
And what we're seeing is
that, in the United States,
every school day
30,000 Chromebooks
are activated every day.
If you look at the
aggregate data,
58% of devices sold in
US schools last year
were Chromebooks.
So, it's more Chromebooks than
all other devices combined.
And Chromebooks
adoption is also growing
in international markets.
So, future stores recently
announced just a few days ago,
that Chromebooks were also the
best selling devices in Sweden.
So, Chrome has been doing
very well in education.
But beyond education, and this
is I think mainly a business
audience, we're
also seeing increase
in popularity of Chromebooks.
So, in retail, which is
consumers buying Chromebooks
from Best Buy, Amazon, there
was a 20% growth last year
in the United States.
And this is in a
declining market.
So, Chrome continues to be the
bright spot which is growing.
In businesses, according
to IDC, 800,000 Chromebooks
were bought by
businesses last year.
And thanks to our users and the
adoption which we are seeing,
Chrome OS was the second most
popular productivity operating
system in the United
States for all of 2016.
And another
interesting data point
which IDC informed
us about that, that
on their FutureScape survey,
and it said, by 2018,
25% of Fortune 500 companies are
going to have some form of ID
supported Chrome devices
in their organization.
So, in case you
are wondering, what
are the organizations--
these are
some of the organizations
who are using Chromebooks,
or Chrome devices,
who have given us
permission to use their names
and share them with you.
So, you can see they
span a whole range.
I don't know if anyone is seeing
their own company on this one.
But you can see the range from
retailers, to health care,
to financial services.
So, it's a very good
mix of businesses
that are using Chrome
devices at this point.
So let's switch
gears a little bit,
and let's talk a little bit more
about Chrome devices at work,
and how are businesses
using these devices.
So, we're actually seeing a
lot of usage of Chrome devices
by businesses to expand
the use of computing.
So, we are seeing them
use Chrome devices
to take computing where they
didn't have computing before.
So, an example of it is we are
seeing businesses use devices--
their employees are
using it every day.
And oftentimes, they are
using it in a shared setting.
Some of the places
where we are seeing this
is in retail backrooms.
You're seeing it on
manufacturing floors.
We are seeing it in
assisted living centers.
We are seeing it in libraries.
We are seeing it in
government facilities.
So, if you think about
it, this use case actually
is kind of analogous
to schools, where
businesses want to get
computing to more employees.
They can share the device.
It's very shareable.
It's very simple.
It's very easy for IT
administrators to manage.
So, another area
where we are beginning
to see a lot of Chrome usage
is digital signs and kiosks.
So, kiosks-- an example
of that would be you
go to a hotel lobby and
you want to check in.
Right?
So, that is using-- running
a single application.
Or an example could also
be a public session,
where, again, if you
think about a hotel,
they want to have a device where
any guest can go and use it.
And they can use
it for browsing.
They could do some
web based email.
So, it's a shared device
for the guest to use.
The other one is digital signs.
So, in digital signs--
again, we are seeing
different types of usage.
So, if you look
at digital signs,
we are seeing, for
example, restaurant chains
use it to show their menus.
So its using a
single application
and you can order from these.
And because these devices
are so easy to manage,
and you can do all of
the management remotely,
it's very cost effective
for businesses to do this.
Another example,
which we are seeing,
is retailers using
promotional video.
So, at your retail
sales point you
are running promotional video.
And again, you can push that
remotely, you can manage it,
you can ping these devices
to see how they're doing.
So, we are beginning to see
a lot of different usage.
And with Android applications
coming to these Chrome devices,
the number of uses which you
can get from them is increasing.
So, you can start getting your
favorite Android applications
on these devices.
And we will be showing
you some examples
of those applications--
Shahid will be doing that.
But in addition to that, another
thing which we are seeing
is that a lot of business
actually develop custom Android
applications already.
And currently they can
use those applications
either on the phones
or on the tablets.
And some of the
example applications--
it could be an employee
scheduling application.
It could be an inventory
management application.
It could be a charting
application for patients.
So, now what we are seeing is
we are seeing these businesses
start to test these applications
on their Chromebooks.
So, now from a
usage point of view
they have the same application
running all the way
from their phones, to
tablets, to laptops.
So, it provides a very
consistent experience
for their users and
their employees.
So, Chrome comes in
multiple form factors.
So, Chrome devices come
in multiple form factors.
We have the Chromebooks,
which are the laptops.
We have Chromeboxes, which
are the mini desktops--
Chromebase, which
is the all in one,
and also the Chromebit,
which is a small stick
which you can attach
to your monitor
to create a digital sign
very cost effectively.
So, depending on
your application,
you can choose the
right form factor which
is best for your business.
And all of these devices can
be managed from the same Chrome
Device Management Console.
And here is a sampling
of some of the devices
we have in market today.
So, this is a sampling.
This is not all of the devices.
So, as you can see,
almost all global OEMs
are building Chrome devices--
whether it's ASUS, Lenovo,
Acer, HP, AOpen, Samsung.
So, there's a variety of OEMs
who are building these devices
and bringing them to market.
So, you have a choice of OEMs.
The other thing, if you're
not familiar with it--
there is a whole
range of form factors.
So, not only do you
have clamshells,
you also have reversible
or convertible devices.
You also have signage devices,
which is the AOpen Chromebox
mini, or the AOpen Chromebase.
You have the ASUS Chromebit,
which is the stick itself.
And last year we also
launched several devices
specifically for work.
So, we have the
HP Chromebook 13.
We have the Lenovo ThinkPad 13.
This is a Chromebook 14.
So, there's a whole
range of devices.
Chrome has a very--
there is a lot of
variety to choose from,
depending on your
application and use case.
I mentioned the Chrome
Management Console before,
but it comes with a
lot of different app
man-- it comes with full
management capabilities.
And on the devices, also,
I should have said it--
if you look at a
device portfolio,
we are continually expanding
the device portfolio.
So, we have evolved
the device portfolio
recently to add devices
which are optimized
for Android applications.
So, same for the Chrome
Management Console.
The Chrome Management
Console it also
keeps evolving to add
new functionality.
And some of the
new functionality
which we have added
is the ability
to manage Android applications
for your Chrome devices
from the same
management console.
So, if you have legacy
infrastructure--
and this is a lot of the
work which team has done over
the last year and a half--
then that legacy
infrastructure works very well
with Chrome devices.
If you have-- you can
get app compatibility.
You obviously have
the web applications.
Android applications are coming.
But we have a variety of
virtualization providers,
Citrix VMware,
Amazon WorkSpaces.
Identity-- so in
terms of identity,
single sign on is
supported-- and again,
through a variety of providers.
So, Okta is one of them,
Bing is another one.
Peripherals-- we added support
for USB C docking last year.
And in terms of printers,
you can support printing
in two different ways,
either the Cloud Print,
or there's a Chrome app
through which you can--
HP Chrome app, through which
100 million plus HP printers
can be used, along with
your Chrome devices.
And then, in terms
of connectivity,
we also provide a
variety of providers,
using which businesses
can connect securely.
And some of the examples of
those, Apollo Alternate Works
and Dell SonicWall.
So, if you have
legacy infrastructure
and you want to apply
Chromebooks in that context,
please contact us, and we are
happy to work with you on that.
So, before we talked
about Android apps,
we wanted to give you
context on Chrome overall.
And we also wanted to talk
about Chrome devices for work.
For the rest of
this discussion, we
are going to be focusing on
Android apps for Chromebooks.
So, we are going to
talk about a few things.
First, we are going to talk
about our design approaches,
and what kind of
design choices did we
make so that it would be a
consistent and good experience,
which adds to the
strength of the products,
so users get the best
possible experience.
So, we'll talk about
some of the devices which
have been built recently,
which are optimized,
or which are designed with
the Play Store in mind--
with the Google
Play Store in mind.
And then we are going to be
showing some app examples.
We are going to be doing a
demo, show you some sample apps.
And then we are going
to end with tips
for optimizing your Android
apps on Chromebooks.
So, that's a run through of
what we will be talking about.
So, lets talk a little bit
about the design choices
which we made.
So, Chrome OS is Google's
productivity operating system.
Because it's a productivity
operating system,
users want to be
able to multitask.
They want to be able to
use multiple windows.
resize their windows.
One of the things which
I think users really
love about Chromebooks,
is it comes
with a Chrome Browser,
the desktop Chrome
Browser, with support for full
extensions, tabs, productivity.
So, the Chrome Browser is
there so you can still use
all of your web applications.
But the way we have brought
the Android applications
to Chromebooks is you
still get multiple windows
with your Android applications.
So, you could be running
different Android applications
in different windows.
You can resize the
Android application
depending on the capability
of the application.
So, the design itself
is focused on ensuring
that users can be
productive, and they
can do multitasking on
these large screens.
If manageability-- I think we
have already touched on that.
We made sure that
manageability was included.
It's a very-- so the simplicity
continues for administrators.
Then, if you look at the--
if you think about
Google Play, and if you
think about the
billions of users
who are using Android
applications in Android phones
today, we also
wanted to make sure
that they had a consistent
experience when they
started using these Android--
when they started using
the Android applications
on their Chrome devices.
So, Android applications
are touch optimized.
But Chromebooks have
different capabilities.
In addition to-- some of
them have touchscreen,
some of them don't.
But they have capabilities--
like you have the trackpad.
So, just as you would
use your finger--
I have a precision
touch trackpad.
So, you can use your
trackpad in order
to navigate the touch elements
on these applications.
And you can click on them.
So, for a user who's used
to doing that on his phone--
when they come over here, it's
a very natural motion for them
to start using their track pad.
Of course, they get their
familiar applications.
The other thing, is if you look
at the Android applications,
most Android applications are
designed with offline in mind.
So, when I'm on an airplane and
I'm using my Android phone--
I mean, obviously, I use the
Google Nexus or Google Pixel
phones.
So, at that point I can do any--
I can work.
I can do a lot.
I can read books.
I can play games.
I can listen to music.
I can do a variety of things.
And it all works when
I'm disconnected,
and when I'm on the airplane.
And I can do all of that
on my Android application
with my Chromebook as well.
So that's very good
for Chromebooks.
But that's also really
consistent from a user
point of view.
The other thing is the
way we have brought
the Android applications,
or the Google Play
Store to Chromebook, is that
it is a native implementation,
and it supports a wide
set of Android APIs.
So, from a user
perspective you're
going to get good performance.
And you're going to get a
consistent UI experience.
So, again, we tried to just
go after the design in a way
that it's a great
experience for people
who are used to being productive
on their Chrome devices.
But also for the
users who are used
to using Android applications
on the Google Play Store,
they also get a very
positive and a really
good and consistent experience.
So, in terms of what kind of
applications are available,
almost all Android
applications are
eligible for Chrome devices.
Some exceptions are
going to be applications
which require special sensors.
So, if your application
requires a GPS,
and a Chromebook does not have
GPS, we'll filter that out.
In terms of how users
are going to access--
so the applications--
so, remember
I said Chromebooks
are very shareable.
Which means any user can
sign into any Chrome device
and they get that same
consistent experience.
So, the Android
applications are also
tied to a user account, which
means that any Chromebook--
if I go from this Chromebook
to this Chromebook,
it will download my
Android applications,
and I'll be able to use them.
And for those who have
purchased Android applications
on another device, the
same purchased application
is going to work on
your Chrome devices.
A little bit more details
about the app management part,
and how the Chrome device
management experiences.
It's centralized
application management.
So, as an administrator,
you're going
to approve all Android
applications that
can be used in your managed
environment, for your managed
Chromebooks.
So, it's a central opt-in model.
You approve all of them.
And then, in terms of curating
the applications for the users,
it can be done in
two different ways.
You can say that
your users can--
you allow your users to
install applications, which
means it's your user's choice.
If they want, they can
install that application.
Or, you can push the
applications to the users
so it's default on their device
when they open up the device,
and when they log in.
Again, as an administrator
you have full control,
and you should be able to
manage all of your Android
applications in a way
that is very consistent,
and it's also flexible.
And the unit is at
the OU level, which
means however you have
set up your user groups
is going to work in terms
of managing your Android
application.
So, if you're a business, if
you have multiple locations,
different functions, you want
to set up Android applications
in different ways for
these user groups,
then you can do that
using the Chrome
administrative capabilities.
So, one of my colleagues
gave a talk yesterday,
and as part of
that she announced
that Android Kiosks apps are
also coming to Chrome OS.
It'll come with the Chrome
OS 57 release, which
is literally in a few days.
Which means that on
your kiosk, if you're
using Chrome as a
kiosk device, which
means you are running
a single application
in an immersive
mode, you will be
able to also run
Android apps there.
And some of the examples
of Android apps--
one of the examples is, I think
Hyatt has a room control app.
That's a kiosk app which
can run on your device.
So, you could set
up a Chrome device,
if you have an equivalent
app in your hotel room,
and you could just use the
same Android application.
Another one which
is being mentioned
is this crowdDJ, which is
for managing nightclubs,
for those who are
in that business.
So again, we wanted to make sure
that Android apps are supported
for all form factors
and all use cases.
So, we have that for the
general user use case,
but also for the
kiosk use cases.
So, I'm going to switch
gears a little bit,
and I'm going to talk
to you about Android--
about the new Chromebooks, which
have been designed with Google
Play in mind.
So, as I said
before, we continue
to work with the OEM partners.
And we pretty much
work with them
continuously to evolve
the range of Chromebooks.
And as part of the Google Play
Store coming to Chromebooks,
we wanted to make sure that
we had the right devices.
We were working on devices which
can really delight the users,
in terms of the Android
application experience.
So, at CES this year,
along with Samsung,
we announced Samsung Chromebook
Pro, and Sampson Chromebook
Plus.
So, these are devices, and
I have one of these here--
and we do have, by the
way, a few other devices,
if you have time later
to take a look at it.
So this is the Samsung
Chromebook Plus.
So, its a convertible, so
you can use it as a notebook.
The screen-- and you can
come check it out later.
Its a beautiful quad HD screen.
This actually has
a built in pen.
So, it has a built in pen,
which you can take out.
So, now you're able to write
on these devices as well.
The other design choice
which we made, is it's
actually a 3 is to 2 screen.
What this means is that
the screen is squarer,
but that means you can use it
as a tablet in any orientation.
So, those are some
of the optimizations
done on the hardware.
And it's pretty thin and light.
So, you can come
and check it out.
This comes with the Google Play
Store right out of the box.
Which means that you get
Android applications,
and you can do more
things with this device
as soon as you get it to your
house, or to your business.
And of course, it has all of
the goodness of the Chrome
Operating System.
So, it has the speed, security,
simplicity, shareability,
and then, now a lot more
offline capabilities
with the Android applications.
So, in terms of
Chromebook Pro and Plus,
which are the two devices
which were announced,
Chromebook Plus was
the one I showed you.
It's already in market.
And Chromebook Plus,
it's powered by an ARM,
OP1 processor.
Chromebook Pro will be
coming to market in April.
It's going to be a
black color device.
It's very professional looking.
And then, also, it's going
to have the Intel Core M3
processor.
So, it will be in
market in April,
but Plus is in market right now.
So I also wanted to point
out that we have been working
with the OEM partners
to build rugged devices,
mainly for education use.
So Acer, ASUS, HP--
all of them announced devices
recently for rugged devices
which are convertibles, and
which have stylus support.
These are Chrome devices-- and
again, I have some of these--
I have a couple of them here.
You can check them out later.
This is the Acer device, and
you can see it's pretty rugged.
This is the HP device, and
this is also a ruggged device.
So, we expect schools to
start using these devices.
We are seeing a lot
of good interest.
And then again, these
are convertible,
and they come with pen.
So, in terms of the pen
technology, we have--
you can see the Samsung
devices have pen built in.
These are a couple
of [? leg ?] pens.
And again, if
you're a school, you
can use different types of pens.
The pen technology
which we are using
is EMR, which means that the
pen itself is very affordable.
It's not an active pen.
You don't need to charge
it, which we think
should be really positive.
And while this is mainly
designed for education,
we are hitting some interesting
use cases from businesses
as well.
So, one of the use cases
which we are hearing
is for backroom
software, like retailers,
for people who want to do
their inventory management.
They are interested
in devices like this,
because they also have one
interesting new feature, which
we didn't have on
Chromebooks before.
They actually have
a second camera,
which is on the c panel.
Which means that you
could use these devices--
I could just go over them, and
there's a camera over here,
so I could take
photos of storerooms,
and I could record that.
So, we are starting to
diversify the range of devices.
Obviously, these
are the first set
of devices which have come in.
Again, depending on
your application,
we are trying to go
more into, you know,
you can use it as a tablet.
You can use it as a PC.
You can have different
forms of input.
You can touch.
You can write.
You can obviously type on it.
And they will continue
to evolve in the future.
So with that, I'm going to
invite my colleague Shahid,
and Shahid is going to come and
talk to you about Android apps,
and give you some demos.
SHAHID HUSSAIN: OK.
Thanks, Smita.
So, my name is Shahid.
I'm a product
manager on Chrome OS.
I have a rather selfish
question, actually,
to begin with.
So, those of you who have
used Chromebooks in the past,
or are using Chromebooks--
can you raise your hand?
OK.
That's good.
Do you have Chromebooks
in the room?
I spot a few here and there.
If you have one,
could you hold it up?
OK.
Thank you.
Thank you very much
for using Chromebooks.
We're very excited,
and all of us
on a team who work
on this stuff are
super excited when we see stuff
being used by folks like you.
So, thanks for that.
OK.
So, we're going to talk a little
bit more about Android apps.
So, Android apps
coming on to Chrome OS.
First of all, let's
start with Chromebooks.
Chromebooks, as
you know, already
have this best in
class web experience.
They came with Chrome baked
in from the very beginning.
Chrome-- now the most
popular browser in the world.
And bringing the Google
Play Store on to Chrome OS
has let our users do
a little bit more,
from design, to
team communications,
to simple but critical
tasks like note taking.
So, now you can use
those apps as part
of your desktop workflow.
So, rather than having
to pull out a phone
and refer to something on there
and have multiple devices,
you can just alt
tab between apps
which you're used to seeing
on mobile now on desktops.
So, integrating it part
into the same workflow
that you're already used to.
And in fact, we've
been already working
with a ton of key
developers to ensure
that the apps that you're
starting to see on Chrome OS
are optimized for Chrome OS.
So, some of those are internal
things, but many of them
are external.
And we're finding that as we
talk to more and more external
teams, that they're really
excited about extending out
their products, their
existing code bases,
into the desktop environment.
Now, of course, that
environment is a little bit
different to mobile.
On mobile you have a
screen that's this big,
and the primary mode of
interaction is touch.
But on the desktop,
the screen is this big,
and the primary
mode of interaction
is keyboard and
touchpad or mouse.
Now, that means that
the type of work
that you're going to be doing
with that app can be different.
The amount of information
that comes to you on a screen
that big can be a lot denser.
The speed of input
with a keyboard
can be a lot faster
than it is with touch.
And the accuracy of you're
pointing with a touchpad
can be much better too.
So, that means that
the types of activities
you can do in those apps on
desktop can be different.
So that's one aspect.
But also, the business
models can be different too.
So, the really
simplistic example
is on mobile it's
very usual to sell
an app for $1, $2 at a time.
And having price points
higher than that is unusual.
It's unusual.
On desktop, however, a
price point of $200 to $300,
for example--
that's pretty normal.
So, that different type of
revenue model for the app,
and that different type of
interaction modes for the app,
has brought us into a
really exciting new era
for Android apps.
So, that's great for developers.
And it's also great
for users, who
are starting to see the Google
Play Store already coming
into multiple Chromebooks,
along with the millions of apps
that that brings.
So, rather than just
talk about this,
we're going to show
you the apps in action.
So, if we could just switch
to the Chromecast, please?
OK.
Could we switch over
to the Chromcast view?
That'd be great.
OK.
Let me see if--
OK, I need to recast.
OK.
Should be good.
Perfect.
Thank you.
OK.
So, here we have an
example developer
that we've been working
very closely with, Slack.
So, I'm sitting in a
room with a colleague,
and my colleague is
reminding me that I
need to dress a little
bit differently today.
So, I usually wear
hoodies, but today it's
dress up a little
bit since we're
at an enterprise conference.
And I can reply back
and say, thanks.
OK.
And that's an example
of an interaction
that we take for
granted on desktop.
I can type a message,
and hit Enter,
and it sends the message back.
Now, on mobile that's a
really unusual interaction
because there's
often no keyboard
attached to those
mobile devices.
And so, that's an example
of the kind of thing
that an app developer will
need to keep an eye out
for when we move on to desktop.
And my colleague, Luis, will
talk a little bit about that
shortly.
But in this case,
I can hit enter,
and rather than doing
a carriage return,
it'll just send the message.
If we could switch to
the camera, please?
Thanks.
So, now I'm going to
show you another utility.
So, as well as
these kinds of apps
that you're used to, like
Slack, all of the utility
apps that you're
used to on mobile
are also coming to Android.
So, as Smita mentioned
earlier, this device,
the Samsung Chromebook Plus,
has a stylus built into it.
And as I eject it,
you'll see there's
a menu that pops up
on screen, that shows
me some options for the stylus.
So, if we could switch back
to the Chromecast, please?
Great, thanks.
So, this menu has just
some quick tools in,
like, for example,
a laser pointer mode
so I can highlight
things for presentations,
like we're doing right now.
But I'm just going
to turn that off.
So, I'm going to
switch to another app
that we've been working
with closely, Evernote.
So, I'm going to convert this
device from the laptop form
factor into the
tablet form factor,
so I can do things like
handwriting much more easily.
So that's exactly what
we're going to do.
So, I'm going to add a
new handwriting note.
So, imagine I'm in a
meeting, and I just
need to take a few quick notes.
So, I'm going to take notes.
Next, OK.
And we're going to have a blazer
and shoes, not trainers, which
is what I usually wear.
And because I'm
doing this digitally
I can do select, reposition
things to be where I want,
erase, restore, et cetera, all
of those kinds of functions.
So, that's great.
But now, because I'm on
a convertible device--
the Samsung Chromebook--
I can switch out to
see this same note.
That's going to head
back into it here.
OK.
And I can actually add
just typed notes onto this
if I want to.
Because my handwriting,
as you can see,
is pretty atrocious, if I
have a couple of minutes
after this meeting, I can
just convert these notes
into typed text, and then
send them out to my colleagues
afterwards-- something
they can actually read.
So, that's just a
couple of the apps
that we wanted to show you
that we have live here.
If we just head back
to the slides, please.
Thanks.
But we also wanted to showcase
a few other apps very briefly.
So, these Android apps aren't
just about Google Apps.
Third party apps
like you've seen,
and one of the key
non Google apps
that we've had requests for is
Skype and Skype for Business.
So, that's already
available in the Play Store,
and you can go and install that
and use it, the same as you
would on your mobile devices.
Evernote, which
syncs across devices,
so you can start exactly
where you left off.
So, as in this case,
I can now pull out
my phone, which is already
logged into the same account,
and add on to that same
note, or start a new one.
And that will be synchronized
across all of these devices.
Slack-- for efficient
team communication,
and rich notifications.
So, inside that app,
if I get more messages
from my colleagues for
a chat room that I'm in,
that rich notification
will pop up in the same way
that it would as if I
was on a mobile device.
A ton of Google Apps,
like, for example,
Google Calendar--
and the advantage
here is that they work offline.
So, you can check into
and read all of that data
in the same way you would
as if you're on mobile.
And for those of you in
the education space--
and just a quick show
of hands, who here is?
--OK.
Fantastic.
Thank you.
So, for those of you--
Play brings a host of
education apps to Chrome OS.
Those apps are easy to
manage in the same way
that, for those of you
who have Chromebook
deployments in education,
you're already used to.
So, admins can push
those Android apps
to compatible devices, just,
very simply through the Chrome
Management Console.
It is genuinely very easy.
I'll have Q and As at
the end, if that's OK.
But thanks.
And it's trues of
turnkey app deployment.
The other thing we
wanted to just call out
is that Adobe recently
announced with us
at [? the Bet ?]
conference, that there
is a forthcoming release of
updated Adobe Android apps
that are optimized for Chrome
OS, specifically for education.
That will help students
harness their creativity
and develop key creative skills
that they can use as they
progress through that career.
So, that's a little bit
about some of the apps
that already exist.
But now, I'd like to turn
over to my colleague, Luis.
He's going to tell
you a little bit more
how you can optimize your apps.
LUIS HÉCTOR CHÁVEZ:
Thanks, Shahid.
So, my name is
Luis Héctor Chávez.
I'm one of the engineers
in the team that
made it possible to run Android
applications in Chrome OS.
So, this section of
the talk is actually
aimed at developers in the
room, which I think is just one.
And it's about the
best practices,
so you can provide a
much better Android
experience on Chromebooks.
So, first of all, we are running
a fully CTS and GTS compliant
Android system on Chrome OS.
This means that
most applications
can run in Chrome OS without
any modifications on your part.
There's absolutely no
code changes required.
But as Smita mentioned earlier,
most Android applications
are optimized for touch in a
very different physical form
factor and device model.
So, you may still want to
optimize your application
so it runs even
better on Chromebooks.
There is a very wide variety
of Chromebook form factors.
Most of them will have a
physical keyboard and trackpad.
Some of them will support
touching the screen.
And others will support
alternative input mechanisms,
like the stylus
we showed earlier.
While we were testing
applications, a lot of them
were already working great with
all of these input mechanisms.
Still, not all of
these applications did.
So, you need to
make sure that you
can fall back gracefully
whenever users are interacting
with your app using a
keyboard, touchpad, or even
a physical mouse, instead
of touch or stylus.
One other thing
you can consider,
is that given that
most Chromebooks will
have a physical keyboard,
productivity applications
can become even more productive
by adding some features
like hot keys support.
In general, Chromebooks
support less amount
of sensors than mobile devices.
For instance, most
Android developers
are used to having a physical
GPS sensor on their devices.
Chromebooks are not
equipped with one.
But you can still
get [? course ?]
location information thanks
to the use of Wi-Fi, which
works OK for most situations.
Chromebooks also have partial
support for other sensors,
like accelerometers
and gyroscopes.
For an exhaustive
list of which sensors
we do support in
Chrombooks books
and the capabilities in
which we support them,
please visit
developer.android.com.
for the full list.
Another thing that
differentiates Chromebooks
from other Android
devices, is that the screen
is much larger and wider
in its default orientation.
You will have a lot more screen
real estate available now,
so it's better if you make the
best use of it as possible.
Make sure your
application can leverage
the full width of the device,
instead of constraining
yourself to a narrow strip
of content in the middle,
like we see in
the pictures here.
One of the top sources of
unexpected behavior of Android
apps on Chromebooks
is due to the screen
being a lot larger
than expected.
So, please make sure
to take this into
account when
developing your app.
Using backup and
restore effectively
is also very important.
As my colleagues have mentioned
earlier, one of the best
features of our Chromebooks,
is that users can just
grab any machine from a
pool of shared devices,
log into that Chromebook,
and all their applications
will be there.
Having said that,
we, as Chrome OS,
don't support synchronizing
the apps data.
That's something you as
app developers need to do.
In order to do that, please make
sure you use Android's default
backup and restore APIs.
That will make your users way
more happy and productive.
One caveat is that local storage
on the device is not infinite.
So, if too many users log
into one device, at some point
we'll need to evict some of
the older accounts, together
with the local storage.
So, please take
this into account.
Chromebooks are currently
shipping with Marshmallow APIs.
But you need to
make sure to plan
to move to Nougat as
soon as possible-- today,
if it's a possibility, since
several things will improve
as soon as you move to Nougat.
And we will be shipping Nougat
later this year as well,
for Chromebooks.
The most important thing is
that if you add support for it,
your applications will be
able to resize arbitrarily,
instead of being constrained to
just one or two orientations.
You'll be able to make
your applications feel
more natural with the rest
of the operating system.
Other APIs you'll be able to
leverage by switching to Nougat
are drag and drop across
applications, and mouse cursor
APIs.
This will improve the desktop
experience significantly.
So, by being ready
for Nougat, you
make sure that your
application will
leverage these APIs as soon
as we convert to Chromebooks.
And with that, back to Smita.
SMITA HASHIM: Thanks,
Luis and Shahid.
So, this wraps up
our presentation.
So, some of the
things we went over,
we talked a little bit
about the Chrome Operating
System, Chrome devices for
work, some of the design
approaches we took, devices
designed for Google Play Store.
We talked about Android
apps, demoed some showcase,
and tips for optimizing.
So, these are some
of the resources
which are available for
you to explore more.
Optimizing apps for Chromebooks,
Chromebooks with Android
application-- so, this
tells which Chrome devices
will be getting the Android
applications, or the Google
Play Store-- which
ones already have it.
And then, also,
articles on how do you
manage Android applications
on Chromebooks.
If you search, these
will pretty much
be the top articles which
are going to pop up.
So, feel free to look for
these and get more information.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]